[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
انفجار يهز منطقه تقسيم في اسطنبول يصفر
عن قتلى وجرحى واردوغان يتوعد
الشيخ سالم الاسبوع
بعد الانتخابات النصفيه
تقول لدينا فرصه
يزيدون الضغط على بوتن مطالباتهم
وبريطانيا
لم تهزم بعد
وقف العربيه 360 ايضا
اخيرا سيلتقي بالرئيس الصيني حاملا كل
ملفات العالم تقريبا
[موسيقى]
82 جريحا جراء وقوع انفجار في شارع
الاستقلال بمنطقه تقسيم هذا ووجهها المدعي
العام في اسطنبول بفتح تحقيق في انفجار
تقسيم مرجحا ان تكون العمليه ارهابيه كما
شهدت منطقه تقسيم السياحيه المزدحمه في
اسطنبول شهدت انتشارا امنيا
عقبه الانفجار الذي خلف قتلى وجرحه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يعد ميدان تقسيم واحدا من ابرز المناطق
السياحيه في اسطنبول ويقع في الجانب
الاوروبي من المدينه الميدان يمثل مركز
اسطنبول الحديثه وتاسس عام
1928 من القرن الماضي في الذكرى الخامسه
لاعلان الجمهوريه يتفرعون من الساحه جاده
او شارع الاستقلال وهو شارع تسوق طويل
الى كيلو و300 متر عند الساعه الرابعه و20
دقيقه مساءا بالتوقيت المحلي وقعا في جارا
في الشارع المزدحم بالمره والمتسوقين
الشرطه التركيه فرضت فوقا امنيا في مكان
التفجير واخلت منطقه تقسيم المجاوره تحسبا
الانفجار اخر وسائل اعلام محليه تحدثت عن
انتشار امني مكثف في منطقه تقسيم وشارع
الاستقلال في وقت تتواصلوا فيها التحقيقات
لمعرفه تفاصيل التفجير
من مره تعرض شارع الاستقلال لسلسله من
التفجيرات القاتله التي تبناها تنظيم داعش
خاصه عام 2015 و 2016 واسفرت حينها عن
سقوط عشرات القتل والجرحى من جهته قال
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان امراه
ضالعه بهجوم تقسيم في اسطنبول مشيرا الى
ان التحقيقات ما زالت جاريه وخلال مؤتمر
صحفي اكد اردوغان ان الهجوم نفذ بقنبله
كان هناك تفجير في شارع الاستقلال ووقع
قتله وجرحى اتمنى شفاء العاجل لهم وتم نقل
الضحايا الى المشافي وسنكشف القائمين على
التفجير وسينالون عقابهم في اسرع وقت
الارهاب لن يصل لمبتغاه والعناصر التي
تحاول النيل من الوحده التركيه لن تحقق
طموحها وسينال المجرمون عقابهم
[موسيقى]
قطاعات الانترنت بتقليد من السطر تواصل
الاجتماعي في تركيا بعد الانفجار الذي
شهدته منطقه تقسيم في وسط مدينه اسطنبول
وقال مرصد لوكس ان الشبكات الاجتماعيه
التي جرى تقييدها شملت تويتر وانستغرام
ويوتيوب وفيسبوك وذلك الانفجار الذي اسفر
عن قتله
تفضل
[موسيقى]
معنى من اسطنبول الكاتب الصحفي اهلا بك
معنا استاذ
ليس هناك الكثير من المعلومات التي تجعل
اي محلل يحكم تماما على ما حدث ولكن على
الاقل من خلال المعطيات التي توفرت لدينا
حتى الساعه ما السيناريو الاقرب من الرابط
الاقرب الى هذا التفجير من المعطيات
المحليه الاقليميه والدوليه
تحيه طيبه مساء الخير اخر تصريحات لنايب
اردوغان فؤاد
ان هذا الانفجار الارهابي قامت بها اييي
امراه انتحاريه
اسفرت عن كما ذكرتم في الاخبار السته قتلى
وحوادث 8 من الجرحى حتى الان لم ااه
يعلن اي جهه او اي همم
منظمه ارهابيه مسئوليتها على الحادث ولا
اهل السلطات التركيه شارت صحيحه في اي جهه
صحيح ذلك
همم نعلم نعم نعم نعلم ان البلاد خاصه همم
يعني
اخر همم من هذه الفتره تعرضت لمثل هذه
الهجمات الارهابيه والتفجيرات الارهابيه
اما منظمه العملاء لكردستان الارهاب
الانفصال او منظمه تعيش المتطرفه
الارهابيه يعني استقدام انتحاريه همم
كانها اسلوب اقرب الى اسلوب الضعش ولكن
كما قلت يعني همم البلاد كانت تشهد هدوءا
واستقرارا همم وامنا اكثر من سته وسبع
سنوات من ذلك انقلاب محاوله الانقلاب وهذا
اول عمل بهذا كبير بهذا الشكل
همم عمليه الانتحاريه او همم امراه لماذا
لا يكون ذلك اقرب الى حزب العمال
الكردستاني مثلا عند همم
كلنا نعلم انك تستخدم انتحار وي يعني
كيسلوب
للعمليات الارهابيه الانتقاميه ووو وتقوم
بمثل هذه التفجيرات هذا لا يعني ان
المنظمات الاخرى مثل البكاكه لا تستخدم
هذا الاسلوب
لا يحمل هذا التفجير بصمه معينه واضحه
لجهه ما اكثر من غيرها
اااه
بلا يعني لا نستطيع تحميل اي جهه همم
لاننا لا نمتلك يعني اشعار
المراه المشتبه بتنفيذها هذه العمليه اذا
وقد تحدث رئيس تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان عن
امراه ضالعه بهذا الهجوم هجوم شارع
الاستقلال في تقسيم في اسطنبول والتحقيقات
لا تزال جاريه وهناك الكثير من التكهنات
بشان هذا الموضوع همم هل داعش من قام بذلك
هل همم الحزب العمال الكردستاني هل جهه
اخرى تماما همم كل شيء لا يزال في اطار
التحليل ولكن هذه الصوره الاوليه التي
تنشر للامراه التي يعتقد انها ضالعه في
هذا التفجير الانتحاريه اذا من خلال
القنبله التي وضعت في حقيبه في شارع
الاستقلال في تقسيم وهو شارع مزدحم عاده
بالمره بالمتفوقين
بالسوريا واتابع معك استاذ اذا ما كان
هناك لديك المزيد من التحليلات ما يتعلق
بالبصمه التي تترك البصمات التي تتركها
هذه العمليه وهمم وبناءا عليه ما الذي
يمكن ان نتوقعه من السلطات همم التركيه
فيما لو كان ذلك داعش او حسب العمال
الكردستاني
في الحقيقه يعني بالنسبه للباصمه او مؤشر
على التي همم تهدد تحدد الجهه لا نمتلك
يعني معلومات مؤكده او واضحه بهذا الخصوص
حتى اللحظه اولويه السلطات الامنيه بكل
تاكيد همم
تحديد المنفذ وكذلك تحديد الجهه التي تقف
وراء هذا الحادث هذا العمل الارهابي ثم
بعد ذلك همم يتخذ تتخذ التدابير اللازمه
اتجاه هذه الجهه ولكن محاربه الارهاب يعني
همم صعبه وشاقه وتاخذ وقتنا همم
هل همم تجد ارتباطات همم
دوليه لما حدث اقليميه بالنسبه لتركيا
ربما تحدث عن شان الروسي الاوكراني ربما
نتحدث عن الشان الايراني ودوليه ايضا يمكن
ان ندرس في ذلك الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
مع كل مستتبعاتها هل تعتقد بانه لكل ذلك
يمكن ان يكون علاقه بما حصل خاصه بموضوع
حزب العمال الكردستاني واشتيارات تركيا في
الفتره الاخيره على السويد وفنلندا همم
سحب الدعم لحزب العمال الكردستاني كي تقبل
تركيا دخول هذين البلدين الى نيته
كل هذه احتمالات فان تتغير
اولاويه
في الترتيب يعني هناك بكل تاكيد يعني
ابعاد خارجيه دوليه او اقليميه لهذا
الحادث على سبيل المثال ليس للالتهام ولكن
على سبيل المثال ايران مثلا على سبيل
المثال من
السياسات التركيه همم
الخارجيه في الفتره الاخيره خاصه التقارب
بين تركيا وبين الدول اسيا الوسطى بين
الدول التركيه الاخرى الناطقه في اللغه
التركيه
همم
وتاسيس منظمه التواليت تركيا كذلك تقارب
تركيا او الخطوات التركيه والطعم التركي
همم والتواجد التركي على الحدود الايرانيه
في القوقاز خاصه اذربيجان
واحتمال
اقتل المصالحه بين اذربيجان وارمانيا
وفتح الممر على الحدود الايرانيه تربط بين
تركيا والاسيا الوسطى كل هذه الامور على
سبيل المثال تزعج الايران وايران همم
احيانا تستقدم مثل هذه الاساليب والادوات
خاصه كانت هناك محاولات ضد السياح
الاسرائيليين وكذلك التقارب تركيا
الاسرائيلي هي الاخرى كذلك تزعج همم يزعج
هذا التراب ولكن حتى اللحظه لم لم تمتلك
همم معلومات همم
كافيه لالتحام اي طرف شكرا جزيلا لك
بطبيعه الحال ولكن التحليل يحتاج الى وضع
كل هذه المعطيات في سياقها على ان تتوفر
لاحقا المعطيات المختلفه لنبني عليها شكرا
جزيلا الكاتب الصحفي من اسطنبول تحيه اليك
الى ذلك اعرضت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه عن
ادانه المملكه باشد العبارات تفجير
الارهابيه الذي استهدف منطقه تقسيم وسط
اسطنبول وادى الى وفاته وجرح عدد من
المدنيين واكدت الخارجيه السعوديه في بيان
ان المملكه تقف مع تركيا ضد هذا العمل
الجبان معربه عن تعازيها لذوي الضحايا
والتمنيات بالشفاء العاجل للمصابيين
الى ملفنا ثاني هذه الليله الانتخابات
النصفيه
[موسيقى]
اعتبرت رئيسه مجلس النواب الامريكي
للاحتفال مشيره الى وجود الكثير من
الاصوات التي لم تحتسب الا انه وفقا
لتقديرات شبكتي سي ان ان او شبكه
211 مقعدا فيما حسم الديمقراطيون 2004
مقاعد في ما لم يتم حسمه مصير 20 مقعدا
بعد
احباط في حزب منقسم على نفسه بعد نتائج
مخيبه للامال حققها الجمهوريون في
انتخابات التجديد النصفي فلم تجري الامور
كما خطط لها كانت بدايه الاشارات السيئه
بخساره محمد اوز لمقعد مجلس الشيوخ في
بنسلفانيا هو المنصب الذي كان يشغله
جمهوري قررت تقاعد ليضيفه الديمقراطيون
اليهم ثم خسر الجمهوريون مقعد الشيوخ في
اريزونا وبعده مباشره خسروا مقعدا بعد ان
تغلبت ديمقراطيه كاثرين كورتيز ماستو على
الجمهوريه
لم تكن هذه النتيجه التي توقعها
الجمهوريون كانوا يريدون موزه حمراء
تمكنهم من تعطيل اداره للعاملين المقبله
فخرج الجمهوريون من نتائج او من انتخابات
مجلس الشيوخ وهم خاسرون ما دخلوا به يبقى
عملهم الان بان يفوز بجورجيا في انتخابات
الاعاده في السادس من ديسمبر يكون حجمه
اقل ليتهم كما كان عليه قبل الانتخابات
لكن ذلك ليس امرا سهلا ايضا ايضا ايضا لم
ينتصر فهو في طريقه لخساره مجلس النواب ما
يعني انه سيطر لتقديم تنازلات للجمهوريين
من اجل تمرير اجنبته حتى انه اعترف
باقترابه من دخول حاله البطه العرجاء
سودان الهاتف
تاتي النتائج بينما ينوي الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب بان يقوم باعلان ضخم في
الخامس عشر من نوفمبر اي بعد يومين وكان
من شبه المؤكد ان يعلن بشكل رسمي ترشحه
لانتخابات 20 24 لكن الرياح السياسيه
معاكسه لطموح الرئيس السابق فقوه الدفع
التي اعتقد الجمهوريون انه سيمنحها لهم
تحولت الى قوه تدمير ذاتي على ما يبدو
كانت رابط دعم في انتخابات مجلس الشيوخ
اعدم لك زعلت من نيفادا وبلايك ماسترز من
اريزونا ومحمد من تنسلفانيا كلهم خسروا لم
ينجح ممن دعامهم ترامب الا جي دي فانز في
اوهايو ورانج جونسون في وسكانسن والاخير
سنه وله رصيده سياسي فلا يمكن نسبه فوزه
الى ترامب امارس في جورجيا فلم يتمكن من
الاطاحه بالمرشح الديمقراطي في الولايه
وذهب معه الى جوله اعاده مصيرها غيره ثم
صراعاته ترامب تسببت ايضا في شرخ في الحزب
الجمهوري لسراعه مع زعيم الحزب في مجلس
الشيوخ متش مكانل كانت ساحه هذا الشرخ
الاسكا حيث قدم الحزب مرشحتين لمنصب مجلس
الشيوخ واحده يدعمها ترامب والاخرى يدعمها
مكانل باموال الحزب ما حرم الجمهوريين من
فرصه تمويل ساحات اخرى حاسمه بدلا من
الاسكا مضمونه كل هذه النتائج تضع ترامب
في موقف صعب امام حزبه الذي يريد الحصول
على دعمه في الانتخابات 20:24
امريكا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ترامب لم يقتنع بالنتائج وقال عبر منسطه
للتواصل الاجتماعي تروس سوشل ان الولايات
المتحده دوله فاشله وان الانتخابات في
نيفادا واريزونا بها تزوير يضيف ترامب ان
الديمقراطيين يختلقون اصواتا في نيفادا
وارينا وانما يحدث عار سياسي الرئيس
السابق قال ان الولايات المتحده دوله
فاشله من دول العالم الثالث حيث تم اجراء
انتخابات ملوثه ستسمح بفتح حدودها ياتي
ذلك بينما يواجه ترامب خساره المرشحه
لمنصب الحاكم في اريزونا وهي كاريك اقرب
حلفائه السياسيين في الوقت الحالي متابعه
ايضا في رصد هذه النتائج بينما يعاني
ترامب من هذه الانتكاسات يبدو انه يخسر
مكانته كذاعيما للحزب الجمهوري مع بروز
نجم جديد
طويله
[تصفيق]
هو حاكم فلوريدا الذي فاز باكتساح في
انتخابات الولايه التي تعد متارجحه بين
الحزبين واستطاع انتزاع مناطق ديمقراطيه
في فلوريدا ميامي ديد انتصار ديسانتس
الكاسح دفعت رامب لشني هجوم عليه وقال انه
سياسي متوسط المستوى ويمارس اللعيب غير
نزيهه ياتي هذا بينما الجمهوري خلف
ديسانتس مثلا صحيفه نيويورك نشرت غلافا
عليه صوره حاكم فلوريدا وعنوان دي فيوتشر
بدلا من ذا فيوتشر اي المستقبل نسبه الى
ديسمبر كان عنوان فوكس نيوز اقرب الى ذلك
حيث وصفت المحطه بالقائد الجديد للحزب
الجمهوريه كما انقلب بعضه المتبرعين
الجمهوريين على ترامب منهم دونالد تيا وهو
احد اكبر المتبرعين وسفير امريكا في
جمايكا خلال اداره ترامب يقول ان اع ترامب
دعمه بعض المرشحين اضر بفرسهم ويؤكد ان
الحسبه كان لديه اقوى حجج سياسيه خلال 20
عاما لكن النتائج لم تعكس ذلك يبقى سؤال
اذا خرج ترامب يوم الثلاثاء لاعلان ترشحه
ما هي قوته السياسيه الحقيقيه بعد نتائج
هذه الانتخابات بعد كل هذه الانتكاسات هذه
هي ترامب اذا ولكن ماذا عن متاعب ايضا
تعهد الجمهوريون بان يبدا عمليه لمحاكمه
بايضا امام مجلس النواب اذا ما استعدوا
السيطره عليها وهو امر غير مستبعد الحدوث
اسباب العزل لم يتم تحديدها بعد البعض
يتحدث عن دوري بيض في الانسحاب الفوضوي من
افغانستان مثلا اخرونا يقولون انه تسبب في
فوضى على الحدود في ملف التعامل مع
المهاجرين
لكن ربما لا يلقى بيدن مصير ترامب فاغلبيه
الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب يعتقد انها
ستكون بسيطه وليس امرا مؤكدا ان كل هؤلاء
الجمهوريين سيصوطون ضد ايضا فالنائب
الجمهوري الذي لن يقتنع بعمليه العزل لن
يحتاج لن يصود ضد قرار زملائه بل سيكتفي
بالامتناع الامتناع عن التصويت وحتى اذا
نجح الجمهوريون في عزل بايضا امام مجلس
النواب فلم يستطيعوا تمرير القرار في مجلس
الشيوخ الذي يسيطر عليه الديمقراطيه
من فضلكم
[موسيقى]
معنى من واشنطن الباحث السياسي دكتور نبيل
ميخائيل اهلا بك معنا دكتور في العربيه
360 كيف باعتقادك انقذ الديمقراطيون ماء
وجههم وكيف خسر الجمهوريون او جعلهم ترامب
يخسرون وتدقق لنا في ذلك لو سمحت
قبل الانتخابات لم يكن هناك توقعات بتساح
احمر او جمهوري كما يظن البعض كل التوقعات
اشارت الى احتمال ان يفوز الجمهوريين
باغلبيه مجلس النواب وهذا عمرو صحيح عندما
تحدث الان يوجد همم 200 211 مقعد لجمهوريه
مقابل 203 لديمقراطيين الاغلبيه هتتحقق
برقم 218 واعتقد ان الجمهوريين سيصلوا الى
هذا الرقم همم زعيم الجمهوريين في مجلس
الشيوخ قال قبل الانتخابات لا اتوقع
اغلبيه جمهوريه في المجلس فهذا امر صحيح
همم هناك قوه استمدها عدد من اعضاء مجلس
الشيوخ من الديمقراطيين كونهم في السلطه
مثل مثلا الانتخابات اللي حصلت مع مايكل
بنت في كلورادو مثل الانتخابات في ني وهي
في غايه الاهميه اا ادم لاكسلت سليل عائله
سياسيه عريقه هو حفيد بول لاكسلت الحاكم
والشيخ السيناتور عن تلك الولايه والصديق
المقرب من رئيس رونالد ريغال خسر بفرق سته
الاف صوت
وهذا رقم ضئيل جدا همم فاعتقد ان هناك نوع
من التوازن في الحياه السياسيه امريكا لكن
الكفه ترجح بعض الشيء الى الجمهوريين
واعتقد ان ترامب فعلا هيرشح نفسه همم منصب
رئيس الجمهوريه ولكن لم يتاذى كثيرا همم
لم تتاذى سمعته كثيرا بعد هذه النتائج الا
يمكن الا يصح القول بان ترامب هو اكبر
خاسرين في هذه الانتخابات وبالتالي
الموضوع قد يحتاج الى تصفيه حسابات في
داخل الحزب الجمهوري
لا اعتقد ان الامور حتمر بالطريقه دي يعني
مثلا الدكتور محمد اوز من اصل تركي خسر
انتخابات مجلس الشيوخ بن سلفانيا انا
شخصيا اعتقد هناك عده اسباب لاني درست
السياسه في بنسلفانيا حيث سياسيه في
بنسلفانيا بدقه احد الاسباب التي جعلته
يخسر كونوا ان هو مسلم لان في فعلا ناس
كانت بتتعصب ضده بسبب عقيدته الدينيه ده
امر لا يمكن يعني انكاره همم مثلا همم
هناك مرشح الخاص همم بلايك ماسترز من
اريزونا نعم ترامب ضربه همم ايددوا لكن هو
شخص غريب الاطوار طرح اولا علاقاته
الاقتصاديه يشبهها همم العديد بنت تساؤلات
التي تحمل الفساد الاقتصادي همم طرح اراء
في التاريخ سخيفه وغبيه همم انت مسؤول عن
تصرفاتك
مسؤول عن اختياراته اذا هو يدعم هؤلاء
اشخاص اذا هو الذي يكون خاسرا في هذه
الحاله وهو الذي يتحمل المسؤوليه على عكس
مقاله هو انه الناجحون يتحمل مسؤوليات
وصولهم والفاشلون لا يتحمل يحملهم هم
مسؤوليه خسارتهم هذا غير منطقي
نعم لكن ايضا على عديد من ايدهم ترامب
نجحوا وهناك همم يعني نوع من اليوتيوب او
التوجه السياسي نحو اليمين الامريكي فلا
يمكن اغفال تلك الحقائق همم على خلفيه
صراعات همم داخليه داخل حسبه او مؤسسه
سياسيه ماء مثلا صحيفه في عددها الصادر
يوم تسعه من هذا الشهر نشرت مقال لنائب
رئيس الامريكي مايك برنس السابق قال انه
يختلف مع ترامب في تصرفاته اثناء احتلال
مبنى الكابيتول هيل يوم السادس من يناير
من العام الماضي لكنه لم يمضي في خصومه مع
هذا الرئيس لان طبعا البلد لا تتحمل مثل
تلك الصراعات الداخليه
فاعتقد ان ترامب لم ينتهي ربما يطلعنا
بمفاجاه سياسيه كبيره عن ترشحه مره اخرى
في ظرف اقل من 48 ساعه على كل حال العوده
وسنتابع ذلك اولا شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور
نبيل ميخائيل الباحث السياسي من واشنطن
تحياتي اليك
باكونا معكم لمتابعه ايضا
روسيا تخسر 50% من الاراضي التي سيطرت
عليها منذ بدايه الحرب وتظاهرات في موسكو
تطالب بقصف واشنطن بالسلاح النوويه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال وزير الدفاع
البريطانيه
عن الاستسلام في اوكرانيا واشار الى ضروره
استغلال الزخم العسكريه
الانسحاب من خرسانه هزيمه لا يبدو ان
مؤيديه الحرب الروسي يستسيغونها بل على
العكس تاثيراتها باتت تاخذهم الى مطالبات
اقل ما توصف بالغريبه او غير الواقعيه قول
هذه المطالبات اتت من اعلامي
الروسيه
في اوروبا لدفع حلف شمال الاطلسي للتراجع
بعد انسحاب روسيا من خيرسون الاوكرانيه
كانت خرسان اكبر مركز حضاري احتلته القوات
الروسيه منذ ان شلنا الكرام لان حربه على
اوكرانيا في الرابع والعشرين من فبراير
الماضي كانت ايضا العاصمه الاقليميه
الوحيده التي استولت عليها موسكو عندما
اجتمع فوتون مع رؤساء المناطق الاربعه في
الثلاثين من سبتمبر الماضي اعلن حينها ان
تلك المناطق اصبحت روسيه الى الابد
ولم يجد لم يدوم ذلك لشهرين ربما يفسر هذا
او يفسر هذا سر الغضب فلاديمير
[موسيقى]
قديم
نيترو
زعم ان الهدف هو اعاده البنيه التحتيه
العسكريه الى خطوط عام
1998 اي قبله ان تنضم دول اوروبا الشرقيه
للحلف مثل لاتفيا واسبانيا وليتوانيا
انه يجب التغلب عليها بقبضه من حديد واضاف
ان ذلك يشمل اطلاقا النار على الجبناء
واعاده الحثاله البكائين الى رشدهم على حد
تعبيرها الاهالي بالاعلام وهتافات ترحيب
ارسلت مواطنه الاوكرانيه صورا لمنازل في
المدينه كانت تحتلها القوات الروسيه اظهرت
الصور غرفا تعرضت مليئه بالقمامه والاشياء
المدمره على الارض وقالت لمجله نيوز ويك
الامريكيه الروس لا يعرفون معنى الحريه
وهم مشبعون بدعايه خاطئه
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه نشرت مقطع فيديو
عبر حسابها في تويتر يجمع مقاطع لسكان
خرسون وهم يلوحون بالاعلام الاوكرانيه
وقالت ان اهالي خرسان لم يستسلموا قط
[موسيقى]
خلال ثمانيه اشهر من الحرب لم يحقق الجيش
الروسي سوى تقدمات ضائله واجبر مرارا على
التراجع نرى هنا مشاهدينا على هذه الخريطه
تظهر الفارق في مساحه السيطره الروسيه في
اوكرانيا بين مارس 20 22 واليوم والتي تعد
اقل بحوالي 50% الان يسمع في روسيا اصوات
اكثر تشددا وان كانت غير واقعيه اذ خرجت
تظاهرات في شوارع موسكو تطالب بشني ضربه
نوويه على واشنطن العاصمه الامريكيه انتشر
مقطع فيديو يظهر رجلا يقود حشدا من الناس
في شوارع موسكو اضربوا مراكز اتخاذ القرار
في واشنطن بصاروخ صار مات اضرب مدن العدو
في واشنطن
ردد المتظاهرون ايضا شعارا يقول سنذهب الى
الجنه كشهداء في اشاره الى التعليقات التي
ادلى بها الرئيس الروسي نفسه عام 2018 في
ذلك الوقت
لا مفر منه وانه سيتم ابادته سنذهب الى
الجنه شهداء
وسيسقطون امواتا ولن يكون لديهم وقت
للتوبه
[موسيقى]
ينظم
هل هذه الاصوات مقبوله
موقف
واقعيه
لما تقوله الروسيه هما يقولون بان العمليه
العسكريه مستمر ولكن
مستعد للمفاوضات مع الجن- اوكراني وحتى
انا اعتقد
تجري هناك
بين روسيا والولايات
المتحدهم موجودين
هناك كثير منها ولكن ايضا هناك هناك
ويهتفون وتنقل وسائل الاعلام همم غضبهم
وفقا رؤاهم على الاقل بايات حال همم هذا
قد يحسب على الرئاسه لانه لم يكن معروفا
كل ذلك التساهل عندما كانت تظاهرات الرفض
للحرب اليس كذلك
يمكن ان نقول بان همم عدد
المتشددين وعدد الرافدين للعمليه العسكريه
هو يعني مساوي تقريبا يعني انا اعتقد طبعا
وهناك موقف متشدد انسحب تعبير الدعم
للعمليه العسكريه ونفس ال- او العكسي موقف
المتشدد الرافد همم العسكريه ويخرجون
هؤلاء الشوارع ويطلبون ايقاف العمليات
التاليه ولكن همم في نهايه المطافك خيريه
المواطنين الروس شخص يريدون بما تقوم به
السلطه الروسيه ولكن دون دون حتى تشدد في
همم في في تعبير عن همم ولكن حتى مسؤولين
كبار استمعنا اليهم كانوا يلمحون همم
ويهددون ظنا باستخدام النووي في كثير من
الاحيان وعلى راسهم
صحيح
حاليا يحاول ان يعبر عن نفسه كانه شخص
متشدد على ما يبدو هو يحاول ان يحصل على
مزيد من الشعبيه من قبل الشعب الروسي بسبب
ان سابقا كان يعتبر كشخص لدرالي همم شخص
الذي يحب الهاتف ايفون الامريكي والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بشكل عام فلذلك حاليا
يحاول ان همم
توزيع ادوار بين القيادات الروسيه همم
لرجل عمل رئيسا لفتره وقوتن رئيس وزراء
وبوتا رئيسا وهو رئيس وزراء والان هو نائب
رئيس مجلس الامن القومي هو في منصب حساس
جدا في السلطه لا اعتقد انه اراؤه تخضع او
تصريحاته تخضع لارائه الشخصيه
هذا المنصب ااا فعلا رفيع جدا ولكن في
نهايه المطاف من يتخذ القرار النهائي هو
الرئيس الروسي فهو القائد العام للقوات
الروسيه
من وجودك معنا لاسالك عن خبر عاجل مستشار
المانيا
حلول او مقترحات لاحلال السلام في
اوكرانيا هل تعتقد ان روسيا في وارد ذلك
الان حقيقه يعني بغض النظر عما يجري تحت
الطاوله من محادثات هنا وهناك
لن اعتقد ان روسيا كانت شفافه حول هذا
الموضوع هي قالت بانه بانها مستعد لجراء
المفاوضات مع الجانب الاوكريدي ولم تتخلى
ابدا عن فكره المفاوضات اعوذ انذاكر ان
تلك المفاوضات قد بدات بعد الايام من بدا
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه كان هناك عده
الجولات ولكن انسحبت من هذه المفاوضات كنا
نحن
هذه الخطوه روسيا لا تظل تصير على استئناف
تلغي المفاوضات
يعني كبيره جدا خاصه مع تشديد مستشار
المانيا الان على ان اي مقترح للسلام يجب
ان يراعي وحده اوكرانيا وسيادتها وهذا
يعني الكثير بعد كل ما فعلته روسيا على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه شكرا جزيلا لكم استاذ
اندريا كوب المحلل سياسي من موسكو تحياتي
اليك
[موسيقى]
الى شرق اسيا توجه الرئيس الامريكي جو
بيدن لبحث المخاطر التي تمثلها كوريا
الشماليه والصين ايضا ايضا التقى زعيمي
اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه في العاصمه
الكمبوديه
لتنسيق ردهم على التهديد الذي تشكله برامج
والبالستيه لكوريا الشماليه الرئيس
الامريكي ناقش مع رئيس الوزراء الياباني
ورئيس كوريا الجنوبيه التجارب الصاروخيه
لكوريا الشماليه التي اطلقت عشرات
الصواريخ في الاسابيع الاخيره بما فيها
صاروخ بالستي عابر للقارات قبل ذلك قال
بيضا انه يخطط للضغط على نظيره الصيني
لاستغلال نفود الصين الفريد على كوريا
الشماليه للحد من سلوكها الذي وصفه
بالعدواني
انت فين انا من الكويت
سيدخل زعيمان القمه بينفس جديد ربما
يعطيهم دفع الى الامام فالرئيس الصيني فاز
بولايه الثالثه بينما خرج بايضا من
الانتخابات التشديد النصفي ليتنفس السعداء
بعد ما تجنب موجه اكتساح من المعارضه
الجمهوريه الرئيس جعل التنافس مع الصين في
النواحي دبلوماسيه والاقتصاديه والعسكريه
وكذلك التقنيه محورا رئيسا لسياسته
الخارجيه التي اعتبرت الصين اكبر تهديدا
للولايات المتحده ومع ذلك دعم بيضا
محادثات بشان مجالات تعاون ضيقه مع الصين
وحتى قبل ان يبدا الاجتماع لا يبدو ان اي
من الزعينين تراجع عن خطوطه الحمراء في
مجالات مختلفه فتايوان جزء من الصين
وستعود بالقوه
بحسب الرئيس الصيني في ما قال الرئيس
الامريكي في الثلاث مناسبات ان الولايات
المتحده ستدافع عسكريا عن تايوان اذا
هاجمتها الصين صحيفه واشنطن بوست قالت في
مقال في مقال تحليليه لها ان الصين تريد
اصلاح العلاقات مع الولايات المتحده لكنها
لن تتخذ الخطوه الاولى واضافت الصحيفه ان
اصلاح العلاقه بين التين و واشنطن
سيتطلبوا اكثر من مجرد اظهار حسن النوايا
وسيحتاج اتفاقا اتفاقا على الجوانب
الاساسيه لهذه العلاقه
[موسيقى]
الصراع بين اكبر اقتصادين في العالم قاد
صندوقا النقد الدولي للتحذير من تداعيات
التنافس الامريكي الصيني على الاقتصاد
العالمي مديره صندوق النقد الدولي
كريستالينا جورج جيفا قالت ان الرسوم
الجمركيه التي فرضها الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب على الواردات الصينيه
بدات تاتي بنتائج عكسيه ومنذ اشهر تحاول
الاداره الامريكيه تخفيفه تكاليف الرسوم
المفروضه على الواردات الصينيه بالتزامن
مع جهود كبح التضخم كما تعلمون الا ان
المناورات العسكريه التي تجريها الصين حول
تايوان دفعت مسؤولي اداره
التفكير بشان الغاء بعض الرسوم او اعاده
فرض الرسوم الاخرى على بكين
حتى الان لم يحل الرئيس جو بايدن بعد
القضيه الرئيسه المتعلقه بالرسوم الجمركيه
التي فرضها سلفه على بضائع الصينيه وكلفت
المستوردين الامريكيين مليارات دولارات
نعود مجددا لمديره صندوق النقد الدولي
كريستالي جورجيا التي قالت لواشنطن بوست
انها كمواطن بلغاريا عاشت الحرب البارده
واعتبرت ان اقتحام جيل جديد في حرب بارده
ثانيه امر غير مسؤول على الاطلاق
[موسيقى]
اذا نزلت يقول انه تم العثور على جثث
مدنيين في منطقه في العربيه 360 ايضا رئيس
مجلس السياده في السودان يؤكد ان الجيش
موجود لو ضلت الحكومه المدنيه طريقها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نفقه الحكومه المصريه
موجوده ازمه في كميات الارز المعروضه في
السوق في السوق الموازيه كما ورد على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
ببعض الشركات لوقف البيع طبقا لمستهلكنا
وتجار تحدثنا اليهم تامر نصره كان هناك
[موسيقى]
لغه كثير سرى حول توفر الارز في الاسواق
وخاصه مع اختفاء بعض اصنافه المعبئه من
قبل مضارب القطاع الخاص هذا الامر نفسه
الحكومه المصريه اكثر من مره خاصه مع
زياده المساحات المزروعه بالارز في محافظه
الدلتا المحافظه اجمالي مساحه الروسي
المنزرعه فيها تقريبا حوالي 800 الف فدان
النسبه دي زادت عن السنه اللي فاتت
بالنسبه تقدر بحوالي من 15 ل 20% تقريبا
عن كل فدان لمخازن وزاره التموين في بدايه
الموسم ولا حقت من يتقاس او يقوم بتخزين
الارز التوريد كان ضعيف شويه في اول
الموسم ما كانش الناس تعرف كثير انت شايف
النهارده في اقبال على التوريد من قبل
المزارعين اما هنا في محافظه القاهره لم
نعود نجد بعض الاسماء التجاريه والعلامات
التي اعتنى عليها عند شراء الارز المعبا
لذلك يقوم ببعض اصحاب محلات البقاله
والسوبر ما ببيع الرز السايب كما يطلق
عليه هنا في مصر في اكياس يعبئونها
بانفسهم وهذا يصعر باكثر قليلا من السعر
الذي نصت عليه الحكومه المصريه بعض اصحاب
المتاجر رفضوا التصوير ولكن من وافق منهم
قال لنا ان الازمه عابره وتحدث كل موسم
حصاد هي الفتره دي اصلا الاسبوعين الجايين
دول اللي هم الموسم بقى بتاع الارز هيبقى
الموضوع بزياده وكل حاجه موجوده كثير يعني
اما في الاسواق فين في المستهلكونه موجوده
ازمه ولكن يشكون ارتفاع السعر لا جامعات
استهلاكيه بنجيب منها
غيري حوالي 7 جنيه 8 جنيه بس موجود
انا مش لاقياه هو مش ازمه بس هو الناس
مخبينه شركات شايلاه عشان حصل له تسعيره
وقالوا انه ب 15 جنيه فاللي عايز يبيع
باكثر من 15يلو الحكومه تؤكدت ان المخزونه
الاستراتيجي من الارز يكفي الاستهلاك
المحلي لمده عام ونفت مدعته صفحات التواصل
الاجتماعي بوجود ازمه في كميات الارز
المعروضه تامر نصره العربيه القاهره
كان اخر الاخبار العاجله عن نيويورك تايمز
تقول الصين وايران تستخدمان محققين خاصين
للتجسس على المعارضين في امريكا وعن
محققين في اف بي اي تنقل نيويورك ايران
حاولت اختطاف صحفيه ايرانيه امريكيه بارزه
تضيف هذه الاخبار عن يور تايمز عن المحقق
كونان في الاف بي ايضا مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي ايران استعنت بمحققين خاصين
لمراقبه الصحفيه مسيحه علي نجاد كان لنا
مقابلات عديده معها على شاشه العربيه
نيويورك
ايضا ايران توظف محققين خاصهين في جميع
انحاء امريكا بشكل متزايد اذا اخر الاخبار
ايضا اكتشاف مو حقيقيين خاصهين تابعينا
لايران في نيويورك وكاليفورنيا اليوم في
العربيه
العالميتين هذه صوره جمعت اخر اربعه رؤساء
وزراء قبل ريشي سوناك ديفيد كاميرون الذي
استقال التزاما بتعهده بانه لن يقود سفينه
الانفصال عن الاتحاد الاوروبي ثم تريزا
ماي التي استقالت لي فشلها في قياده
السفينه ثم بوريس جونسون الذي اطاحت به
فضيحه اقامه حفلات في مقر الحكومه اثناء
اغلاقات كورونا ثم الفضائح التي طالت
طاقمه الحكوميه
واخيراس التي لم تصمد اكثر من 44 يوما بعد
سياسه اقتصاديه تاريخيه تسببت في انهيار
العمله امام الدولار
ايضا عن المحققين في اف بي اي ايران
تستعين بالمحققين لمعرفه مكان اقامه
الاشخاص وهويتهم وفيديو اليوم في العربيه
360 هو من ولايه تكساس الامريكيه حيث حصلت
حادثه اصطدام طائره طين عسكريتين قدمتين
في الجو امام الحشود في معرض جوي تذكري
للحرب العالميه الثانيه تسبب الاصطدام في
تحطيم الطائره الطين او في تحطهم في تحطم
الطائرتين فورا فيما فتحت وكاله الطيران
الاتحاديه الامريكيه تحقيقا
نحن نكتفي بهذا القدر في العربيه 360